es difícil es imposible no no creo que
podamos hablar del mar caribe sin hablar
de la república dominicana principal
destino turístico la economía de mayor
tamaño e incluso la montaña más alta de
todo el caribe amigos desde que pusimos
en marcha este canal uno de los vídeos
que con más insistencia nos habéis
pedido es precisamente uno sobre la
república dominicana pues bien hemos
tardado un poquito pero finalmente ya
está aquí amigos en este vídeo nos vamos
al caribe
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la república dominicana de su lugar muy
pero que muy especial en américa latina'
y no lo digo sólo porque aquí podamos
encontrar rincones tan increíbles como
puntacana vaya ahí veo puerto plata
entre otros muchos sino también porque
esta fue la primera tierra que toco
cristóbal colón' cuando descubrió
américa en 1492 si así es para bien o
para mal aquí comenzó aquí se puso en
marcha lo que conocemos como américa
latina'
[Música]
su capital santo domingo fue la primera
ciudad de todo el continente americano
aquí se construyó la primera catedral la
primera universidad y el primer hospital
pero si es verdad si por algo asociamos
hoy la república dominicana es
precisamente por el turismo
la revolución del sol
y esta es con mucha diferencia la mejor
cara de este país y no es para menos
amigos la república dominicana está de
moda gracias a sus 1.600 kilómetros de
costa a los más de 400 kilómetros de
impresionantes playas caribeñas a sus
campos de golf y a sus enormes resorts
del todo incluido el país está viviendo
un impresionante boom turístico
[Música]
claro que la historia viene de lejos
fijaos ya durante la década de los 40 el
por aquel entonces dictador
plenipotenciario de la isla el general
rafael leónidas trujillo dio la orden de
que se fomentará el turismo
probablemente con la intención de
llenarse aún más los bolsillos de esta
forma en 1944 se inauguró el malecón de
santo domingo y se abrió el primer hotel
de lujo de la ciudad el hotel jaragua
años más tarde en 1968 se aprobó la
primera legislación que consideraba de
interés nacional el desarrollo turístico
así que como veis las cosas vienen de
atrás
[Música]
ahora bien en los últimos años el
despegue ha sido total en 2017 la
república dominicana un país con poco
más de 10 millones de habitantes logró
atraer a más de 7 millones de turistas
[Música]
el crecimiento está siendo tan rápido
que se espera que no más de tres años el
país logrará superar la barrera de los
10 millones de turistas internacionales
e
y desde luego tal y como os podéis
imaginar todo esto tiene consecuencias
en tan solo los últimos cinco años la
inversión extranjera directa en este
sector ha crecido más de un 500 por
ciento es decir se ha multiplicado por 6
hoy la república dominicana tiene más de
80.000 habitaciones de hotel y la cifra
no deja de crecer
para que se hagan una idea para acomodar
a todos esos visitantes en 2017 en los
hoteles dominicanos ya abrieron 8 mil
366 nuevas habitaciones y están en
construcción
unas 15.000 adicionales danilo medina
presidente de la republica dominicana el
resultado el turismo es ya la principal
actividad económica de la isla y si
tenemos en cuenta tanto la riqueza que
genera directa como indirectamente
supone 1 de cada 4 pesos que genera la
economía el 25 por ciento podemos decir
que la república dominicana ha
descubierto y está empezando a explotar
su particular petróleo y amigos en esta
línea casi todas las noticias son buenas
fijaos por ejemplo en uno de los últimos
logros cosechados a cambio de romper con
taiwán
el gobierno de la china popular se abre
al turismo dominicano las autoridades
chinas declaran la república dominicana
como destino turístico para sus
ciudadanos claro que espera como relator
porque aquí no termina todo amigos la
república dominicana también tiene otra
cara y es que aquí en este país podemos
encontrar muchas de las luces sí pero
también muchas de las sombras que hoy
encontramos en latinoamérica atentos
[Música]
a otra cara
la república dominicana ha conseguido
tener una de las tasas de crecimiento
más altas de américa latina y el caribe
en los últimos 25 años precisamente este
buen desempeño ha logrado que en paridad
de poder adquisitivo el país tenga una
de las 10 rentas per cápitas más altas
de toda américa latina con casi 17 mil
dólares la república dominicana esta
mano a mano con costa rica y muy por
encima de países como perú colombia o
ecuador
sin embargo esa no es toda la historia a
pesar de todo el 32% de los dominicanos
una de cada tres personas vive por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza la
esperanza media de vida apenas supera
los 70 años y la tasa de mortalidad
infantil es casi 5 veces más alta que en
los países desarrollados
tal vez esta es la razón que explique
que tan solo en los eeuu podamos
encontrar a millón y medio de
dominicanos y que tras el turismo las
remesas sean la segunda mayor fuente de
riqueza pero dicho esto creo que la
pregunta que todos nos podemos hacer es
porque cómo es posible que semejante
paraíso no haya conseguido despegar del
todo
[Música]
pues amigos la respuesta está en que en
esta tierra caribeña vamos a encontrar
algunos de los males que
desgraciadamente están extendidos por
muchos países de latinoamérica
[Música]
si en 1492 aquí comenzó la historia
moderna de la región ahora 500
veintiséis años más tarde encontramos en
este mismo sitio un buen reflejo de lo
mejor y también de lo peor
de latinoamérica pero entrando ya en
materia la primera gran sombra que
podemos encontrar es el empecinamiento
que parece existir en esta región por
las políticas que ya han demostrado una
y otra y otra vez que no funcionan
fijaos por ejemplo en la cuestión del
trabajo informal del empleo irregular
que es un problema en toda la región por
un lado los trabajadores que están
expuestos a esta situación a la
informalidad tienen salarios más bajos
condiciones más precarias mayor
inestabilidad y también problemas para
obtener financiación ya sea para
comprarse una casa para invertir en un
negocio o para formar bien a sus hijos
y es que claro al fin y al cabo una
empresa va a invertir mucho menos dinero
en un empleado si está contratado de
forma irregular por otro lado para el
gobierno también es un problema por
ejemplo a la hora de cobrar impuestos
pues bien en la república dominicana el
empleo informal afecta a seis de cada
diez trabajadores pero es que además en
este país la cifra no sólo no se reduce
sino que está creciendo en 2017 por
ejemplo los únicos puestos de trabajo
formales que se crearon en todo el país
fueron en el sector público y que nos
están diciendo todos estos datos pues
que existen muchas barreras y cargas a
la contratación formal burocracia
impuestos regulaciones desfasadas que
alguien que monta un negocio tenga que
pagar impuestos incluso antes de ganar
un solo dólar etcétera etcétera
y todo eso lógico dificultad que la
economía privada cree empleos de calidad
así que con los datos en la mano creo
que lo normal sería decir oye pues
tendremos que impulsar la contratación
formal cambiando todo lo que no funciona
verdad pues no nada de eso no hay manera
lo mismo pasa con la política comercial
veréis en un país con un mercado local
pequeño como es el caso precisamente de
la república dominicana el sector
exterior es fundamental obvio no pues
bien en este país encontramos por así
decirlo dos situaciones diferentes
fijaos
por un lado las zonas francas donde las
empresas que se instalan tienen
condiciones favorables tanto
regulatorias como fiscales a cambio de
que básicamente sólo se dedican a la
exportación cumplan algunos criterios y
sean aprobadas por el gobierno por otro
lado están las empresas normales que son
por supuesto la inmensa mayoría pues
bien más de la mitad de todas las
exportaciones tienen su origen en las
zonas francas y además en los últimos
años las exportaciones desde estos
lugares vienen creciendo de media más de
un 5% cada año
en cambio las exportaciones de las
empresas dominicanas comunes bueno he
echado un vistazo a este gráfico
[Música]
entonces viendo esto la pregunta que yo
me hago es si las zonas francas
funcionan porque no extender sus
beneficios al resto del país para que
así todas las empresas dominicanas sean
más competitivas pues no tampoco nada de
eso y luego también está el tema del
déficit del gasto público y la deuda que
a pesar de la gran cantidad de malas
experiencias sigue siendo un vicio de
muchos gobernantes de latinoamérica y
rojo también de españa' aquí la
república dominicana tampoco se salva
desde 1990 el gasto público de este país
se ha multiplicado atentos por 18 aquí
el déficit público es casi una tradición
[Música]
tu amor
ahora bien un momento puede que alguno
de vosotros esté pensando pero vamos a
ver enrique este país está saliendo de
la pobreza hay muchas cosas que hacer
hay que crear infraestructuras como
carreteras aeropuertos puertos para
claro que el país crezca pues sabéis
cuál es el tipo de gasto que más crece
no lo siento no es la inversión pública
sino el gasto corriente que se ha
multiplicado por casi 30 30 desde 1990 y
claro el gasto hay que pagarlo una parte
con más impuestos que ralentizan la
creación de empleos formales y la
inversión otra parte se paga con deuda
fijaos fijaos qué está pasando con la
deuda dominicana con la deuda y con los
intereses porque claro la deuda tiene
intereses atentos
i
si tal cual casi 1 de cada 4 dólares que
gasta el gobierno dominicano se va a
pagar intereses es la tercera mayor
cifra de toda américa latina y no para
de crecer vaya negocio pues precisamente
a pesar del despegue del sector
turístico este empecinamiento una y otra
vez con políticas que no funcionan es lo
que explica que los dominicanos tengan
tantos problemas y que aún haya tanta
pobreza en el país
fijaos en cómo se clasifica este país en
el índice de competitividad global
[Música]
pero qué pasa con los políticos será que
están a otra cosa atentos
[Música]
sospechas
amigos la república dominicana es un
país fantástico y tiene un futuro
prometedor y la verdad cuando logre el
gran salto va a ser casi el paraíso
pensarlo un momento buen tiempo buenas
playas y dinero quien se va a resistir
pero hoy por hoy la república dominicana
tiene otros dos problemas muy
importantes que pueden frenar el
despegue del país el primero de ellos es
la corrupción
república dominicana entre los 50 países
más corruptos según transparencia
internacional tal cual como lo escucháis
la república dominicana es considerado
uno de los países más corruptos de todo
el planeta según el ranking de
transparencia internacional tan solo
venezuela haití guatemala y nicaragua
están en peor situación en latinoamérica
aquí la corrupción a todos los niveles
es habitual las sospechas van desde el
actual presidente socialista danilo
medina al que se acusa de haber
financiado su campaña electoral con
coimas y sobornos hasta la propia
policía
hecho en la república dominicana fue
donde la empresa odebrecht instaló su
centro de coordinación de los sobornos
que pagaba a nivel internacional a
cambio de contratos y por supuesto
muchos de estos sobornos se quedaron
aquí casi 100 millones de dólares que se
sepa fueron recibidos por políticos y
funcionarios a cambio de concesiones
adjudicaciones de obras y contratos
públicos
pero desgraciadamente aquí no termina
todo el otro problema que está creciendo
es el narcotráfico veréis la república
dominicana es considerada por los eeuu
como uno de los países puente uno de los
centros de distribución de narcóticos
más importantes
a los narcotraficantes no les resulta
fácil exportar drogas desde venezuela
allí hay pocos vuelos comerciales escaso
tráfico marítimo el sector pesquero ha
colapsado y no hay turismo pero
repúblicadominicana a 1400 kilómetros de
distancia tiene todo esto de hecho según
la dea y los servicios de inteligencia
europeos hoy por hoy la república
dominicana es uno de los principales
países de tránsito para los narcóticos
que se dirigen a eeuu y el más frecuente
de todos para los cargamentos de coca
que se dirigen a europa y evidentemente
esto supone un riesgo importante pero de
todo esto hablaremos en otro vídeo en
cualquier caso amigos que quede claro
estos son problemas desgraciadamente
comunes a casi toda la región la
república dominicana ha conseguido mucho
en las últimas décadas es un lugar
fantástico y su futuro es prometedor en
este vídeo os hemos querido mostrar
algunas de las causas que explican que
las cosas en este país no vayan tan bien
como deberían por cierto uno de los
amigos a los que más aprecio tengo es
precisamente de la república dominicana
así que doy fe de que además aquí hay
gente estupenda en fin si te ha
resultado interesa
este vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte al canal para estar al tanto
de todas nuestras actualizaciones un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]